So if naturalism is the dominant view of the West,
pantheism is the dominant view of the East.
Pantheism is interesting and it may seem like much of
pantheistic thought is far from your students.
And it even though it largely dominates the eastern culture from
hindus to buddhists uh and a bunch of others oh you know in that part of the
world it has made its way to the west and in a really strange way so you might think
for your youth group well why are we talking about pantheism why are we bothering
with this that that's another part of the world and I'm not taking my kids on a
mission trip over there so do I really need to spend an entire week dedicated to a
this sort of eastern thought well do you like star wars
have you ever heard of karma
meditation even yoga all of these things come from
pantheistic thought or a pantheistic worldview so naturally we cannot ignore
its influence we have to address it we have to discuss it And we've got to get our
students to understand what it exactly is so that they can identify it and
navigate through it successfully.
So, what is pantheism? What are we talking about?
So, essentially, think of it this way.
The idea of God, and I'm going to write God in a small g, is in all.
Now, you could even say even more specifically, is all.
Because we talk about, in Christianity, we talk about the idea of the Holy Spirit
being within us, right? So, God is in us.
And that's sort of the idea, right?
Jesus comes. Jesus goes. He sends the Spirit.
The Spirit dwells within us. We have this idea of God in us.
Not just God with us, but God in us.
Well, okay, that's great. But that's not the same thing when we're talking about
pantheism. We're talking about the idea that God is literally part of
everything. So in a pantheistic way, God
would be in me just as much as in the camera that I'm speaking to, as this table,
as this Bible, as this marker, as this whiteboard, rocks, trees, pretty much
all of it, all of nature is all part of the divine.
It's all part of who God is. It's all part of this divine sort of idea
of the universe. It's all combined into one.
There's a divine spark in everything.
It's essentially what pantheism teaches.
So that's where we get this idea of essence or force.
When we talk about in Star Wars, the idea of may the force be with you, that same
kind of idea. It's a divine essence that's part of this.
We can call it a force. There's something going on behind the scenes in everything
else.
So God is present everywhere. So it defines life now.
It defines life later. It defines relationships.
It defines everything, how we see and relate to God.
But the key I want you to get here is the idea of distinction.
And this is going to be important as you move forward, this idea of distinction.
If naturalism is saying there's no God at all, pantheism is saying, well, there is
God, but God is not distinct from anything that's created.
That God is a part of creation. He's a part of you and me.
It's just that there's no distinction.
There's no God and us. There's just everything all together.
So for pantheism, there is no distinction at all.
Okay? So keep that in the back of your mind, especially as we move to next week when
we talk about monotheism. That's going to be really, really important.
So in our Bible study portion, we talk about Paul.
We talk about Paul's interaction at the Areopagus.
On Mars Hill. And we talk about his interaction between the Epicureans and the
Stoics. And what's interesting is that these Stoics actually believed much of the
same kinds of things that modern-day pantheism believes.
That idea that God has somehow packed in every little piece of our
world. And what Paul does, it helps them see that there is
a distinction between the two. That God is here
and we are here. That there's a separation, that although he's personal, although
he's right here with us, he's distinct and other than us.
And that's incredibly important.
Because what this does is the loss of distinction is actually what leads
us to the root of all sin, right?
Of creating God or creating idols that are a substitute for God.
If you'd say that there's no distinction, all of these things are just as divine as
God. So I can worship rocks and trees and everything else.
It's not any different if we don't have some kind of distinction.
So it drives us right back to the root of our sin.
It drives us right back to idolatry.
So your students probably won't see right away, but you need to help them begin to
see how Western culture has actually embraced a lot of pantheistic ideas
about God and creation. Again, let's go back to the buffet.
It's super easy for us to say, wow, it sounds really cool because I can see how
beautiful creation is to want to make that into a God-like thing.
Or I can treat somebody or an activity or I can find a center in myself
and be the kind of person and elevate myself to a
God-like stature. That sounds really cool.
And along the buffet line, it sounds like I can say, well, if I care about people, I
can elevate them to that same status too.
So I like justice. That seems to speak to some of my morality.
It seems you start to again go back to that buffet and start to piece things
together. But when we put them all together, we realize once again that this isn't
coherent and it isn't consistent.
Now, one quick word of note here that I want to make sure that we're
clear on. If you're doing everything really, really well, chances are you have
some students that are either seeking, maybe skeptical,
and got some questions and are curious.
And as we're talking about other worldviews whether they believe these things
specifically or not you want to be careful that we don't offend we
want to be careful that we speak truth that we do so in love but that we help
understand that these things are terribly inconsistent and they don't work but we
need to do without making fun of it we need to do without making light of it.
Because when we're talking about worldviews, as we talked about a few weeks ago,
that these things are ingrained in us and they are embedded in us.
And to change is a huge monumental change and can often, like we said, create some
anxiety. So the last thing we want to do is invite non-believing students, invite
our seekers and our skeptics into our youth space and say, come with your questions,
come with your curiosity and we'll help you navigate and we're going to accept you
but at the same time we're going to sort of make light or make fun of other world
views that's not going to work there's it's very this is a very
popular world view so is naturalism so there's some really really smart people that
have said some really really intelligent things about these world views now that
doesn't make them true but we have to respect what they believe and speak to
how it does not line up with reality and how it does not line up with truth, but do
so in love. So remember, pantheism, God is all.
God is in everything and a part of everything.
The rocks, the trees, everything.
And it's a divine force. And essentially, key word here is there is no distinction
between God and creation, between creator and creation.
And not only does this lead to the idea of idolatry.
If we don't have the distinction, what does that make God?
The very fact that we call him God means that he is completely distinct, completely
other than and completely holy for us or than us.
The idea is if God is here and completely other than me, I have a standard to look
to so I understand what's right and what's wrong.
I understand what's just and unjust.
I understand the idea of love versus hate.
Wait, putting God outside of myself and making God completely
distinct helps us navigate reality in a way that makes sense.
We have to have some kind of distinction.
It's God who is other than, God who is holy, God who is supreme creator over
all. And it's in him that we live and move and have our being.